and in the last few days i've tried to  persuade my colleagues that it would be  eccentric to change governments when  we're delivering so much and when we  have such a vast mandate and when we're  actually only a handful of points behind  in the polls even in mid-term after  quite a few months of pretty relentless  sledging and when  the economic scene is so difficult  domestically and internationally and i  regret and not to have been successful  in those arguments and of course it's  painful and not to be able to see  through so many ideas and projects  myself but as we've seen  at westminster  the herd instinct is powerful when the  herd moves it moves  and my friends in politics no one is  remotely indispensable